so where are we now
uh we're in asana and this list over
here is everything that i wanted to
cover in this course okay
yeah okay so arrays in javascript are
just like lists in this case the zeroth
item is intro after that we have github
and so on i'm really glad you said zero
because javascript arrays are zero index
yeah they sure are
let's take a look
arrays are just lists of values and they
behave the same as lists and python we
start lists with the same syntax as
before with var and then the name of the
array followed by an equal sign the
array will be defined by these square
brackets with items inside separated by
commas
let's make an array of skills
this could be really useful in our
resumes later so i'll go ahead and start
with var skills and then i'll start with
awesomeness
that's not a skill dude it actually is
if you check my linkedin profile then
i've got programming teaching and
javascript all separated by commas
i'll go ahead and append the skills to
the page save it
come over here
hit refresh
and we can see it on the page
it's not separated by any commas or
spaces here because we didn't have any
commas or spaces within the strings in
our skills array
and we can see that we have now just
awesomeness added to the end
of our array
let's say i just wanted to append the
first item awesomeness to the page
instead
i'll start by commenting out this line
and then using bracket notation i'll
append the zeroth item of the skills
array to the main div on the page i'll
go ahead and save this come over to the
browser and hit refresh
and we can see that we just have
awesomeness on the page now because we
use bracket notation
nice
one cool thing is that javascript gives
us a way of accessing properties about
the array
in fact you should give it a try
let's take a quiz